yo what's good American [ __ ] high fee
versus Auto Show baby
yeah and welcome to the episode the
roommates podcast a late-night
conversation take you behind the scenes
of becoming feature all the interesting
people perspective and conversation you
experience on the way also also known as
the best every week where you are
entertained like a stand-up educated
like a TED talk and enlighten like a
sermon baby amen we're doing something
different this week oh good doing
something different this we I thought we
should do one of those Funkmaster Flex
rants go we're gonna go ahead and bring
the roommate in at the beginning I know
we usually don't do this no we don't
know for this roommate I think we got to
go ahead and bring him into the
beginning he's a special guy he's a very
special you guys are looking for ratings
huh but without further ado guys please
introduce our welcome to the podcast
your brand new roommate mr. Gary
Vaynerchuk aka Gary B what up fellas and
thank you so much thrilled to be here
Amy appreciate you person fun with this
you is phenomena how you concentrate
because I'm [ __ ] focus looking at the
garden every day makes it fun I mean I
wish the Knicks were playing a little
bit better but it's funny we moved into
this office there's there's I guess
there's four corners but there was two
core corner offices this side and all
the way on the other opposite side and
the other side is even better in water
it's the Statue of Liberty
oh it's New Jersey I'm an immigrant that
grew up in New Jersey yeah so it's like
me and yet I still was like now I want
to look at the Knicks yeah yeah the
Knicks suck for the last twenty years
that's how much blue and orange I've got
in my body and so not as much as green
with the Jets but yeah this is a nice
view and I owe that rookie a peek in the
thumb really man it's so funny I got
some good text exchanged with my brother
like saying like I really believe in
this kid I'm really excited yet I'd
never watch them play at Kentucky just
completely into it if he goes why I'm
like I don't know I don't have a real
reason here but the way the NBA is going
like I just could see I you know it's
real interesting his first summer league
game it obviously caught a lot of
people's attention I think I'm excited
about it
so whose season are you more excited
about the gym zingers zingers Alfred
until Christmas okay
supporting is out until Christmas
obviously we'll watch Knox develop and
see if Frank the point guard could
develop in Super Mario just sign so he's
an interesting prospect so he might pop
but Sam darn old yeah like they believe
in Sam do you believe in things honestly
so I got some really good we got content
I don't have to documenting my life on
my vlog has been the greatest thing so I
have real content for
some people were listening may know my
brother AJ and I have a separate company
called Vayner Sports which does talent
representation Jerry Maguire [ __ ] and we
courted Arnold and we were in the finals
with him yeah so I sat in sam donaldson
room with his parents pitching them why
should sign with us it we got real close
he didn't go with us I get why
quarterback we didn't we're still young
company I think he was a little scared
but him and I became unbelievably
personally close through the process I
also got fairly close with Josh Rosen
who I love as well so both of them I was
really like you know this would be real
real cool and the way worked out cuz
Baker moved up yeah is that one point as
like [ __ ] Donald's gonna go Browns
Rosa's gonna go Giants your and what are
we gonna do and not that I have to
disrespect the other quarterbacks but
those were the two guys for me uh man
when he got drafted I lost my [ __ ] I
believe in him tremendously and I think
he's much more mobile I think he's more
green than people realize so actually my
only concern is I don't think he's ready
yeah they throw him out too early it's
New York but what's weird about Sam my
personal point of view is his demeanor
some people I think New York you can
only win on two demeanors either Sam's
which i think is more like eli Chile's
[ __ ] like I don't think Sam's gonna be
affected I mean it some people like [ __ ]
yeah Sam sobs it's not even about LA cuz
Sanchez was from LA from LA anything
Sanchez a star there is my guy who goes
out Donald's like stayin in on his 21st
birthday
cerebral good so like when the posts
headline is Sam the suck yeah some
people struggle with that and I just
think it's not gonna affect him you see
so real quick on that go ahead I think
the other way to win New York is like
Jamal Adams hmm right who's our first
pick from the year before he's like mr.
New York out on a bow like he gets his
game going and the Jets get good he's
gonna be a star in this town he's gonna
be courtside at the Knicks yeah he's
gonna be this in that and those are the
only two ways being an alpha alpha dog
like Jamal or being an alpha dog who's
cerebral yeah yeah I think everybody in
the middle gets killed by this town yeah
that's at least my hope no well I was
gonna say you turned me into a believer
in Sam because at first I wasn't a
believer in saying watch Sam playing
college I loved USC big USC fan from the
mat liner days Carson Palmer day so I
followed almost every single quarterback
from USD from that period of time but
your point about the the cerebral miss
in chaos that's my number one thing if I
want if I'm drafting the quarterback or
picking up a quarterback recruiting the
quarterback I'm not looking at
highlights I want to see third and long
I want to see fourth down one to two
minutes or listen I hate him with all my
[ __ ] guts yeah but when the Jets
played the Patriots in 2010 in a Monday
night game the Patriots beat the Jets I
think forty five to three mmm now seven
weeks later two Jets stunned the
Patriots in the playoffs that's why I'm
probably bringing up this yeah there was
a really interesting moment in that game
where Tom brick the Jets are getting
their ass kicked I think at this point
it goes to 28 to 3 and Brady looks over
at the Jets bench and basically says
[ __ ] you right I believe in that too
yeah like this Arriba like again I
believe in opposites yeah yeah yeah like
I think I'm that yeah I think I'm crazy
as [ __ ] competitive high energy but then
I can also be kind and nurturing and the
reason I think I'm popping in like
culture and society is I'm an enigma I'm
different
mmm I'm showing two different things and
depending on the person they're seeing
one of three things one they're seeing
the alpha dog I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
and for a lot of dudes young dudes are
like yeah of it you're right yeah then
other people when they look at my
content they see the kind compassionate
caring patient tried and true
you know who likes that a lot of 40 and
older or wisdom or like even a 19 year
old who's got wisdom they see like the
parent the leader the real [ __ ] deal
they love that too more number three
because you're always finding what
you're looking for the combination of
those two things
the third thing they see is they don't
like me at all mmm because the thing I'm
doing is putting pressure on people yeah
like my content puts pressure yeah like
when you want us to spend time blaming
everybody else you do not consume my
content that's right yeah because you
think I'm an [ __ ]
yeah you think I like you the friends
that you have that don't [ __ ] with me
it's cuz they're still stuck with
excuses and I'm not mad at them yeah i
don't i actually want them to win i'm
hoping that like one time on that
Instagram feed they're gonna see
something and they were ready to hear it
yeah because they realized the excuses
like the excuses part works for no one
Ezra the quarterback that blames their
left tackle losses yes now that that
quarterback thing is big because like
you say you look at all the greats like
no matter what happened like you you hit
em post game interviews and you hear
them talk about like it's all on me I
think that's I think that's a really
dope part and that's life listen to make
it
listen everybody who's listening none of
us are gonna be NFL quarterbacks let's
get it to real life if your job sucks
yeah that's on you in a different job
yeah take a step back my biggest thing
right now that I'm trying to reconcile
is how to get people off of the drug
that's keeping them away from taking a
step back takes two steps forward this
is what I mean if you're making 71,000
because you went to a decent school
collected some debt and you got a good
job but you [ __ ] hate it yeah you
could get 42000 working at Kmart
you could that's room you could make
27,000 working at 7-eleven you could the
reason you don't is because you put some
money down on this fancy apartment the
reason you don't is because you want
some fresh kicks or a phat ride and to
get that girl or whatever like the
reason you don't is because you created
expenses around what you want to achieve
now you're the reason I really won in
hindsight because don't forget my
narrative people who want to like drag
me down or troll me you'll be like yeah
but don't listen to him his dad they
don't know the story they don't I mean
the story just saw everybody's listening
is my work
my whole [ __ ] life 234 years old and
left Wine Library and yeah I built it
from three to sixty but I left with
nothing
yeah I don't own Wine Library I never
made two three four hundred thousand a
year I left with nothing
why did I pull it off because I live in
Springfield New Jersey and paid $1,100
in rent right like and like which is a
lot of money actually yeah yeah you
balling sucks that was like a piece of
[ __ ] Yeah right in the villas on
Springfield Avenue
I bought nothing hmm I had nothing I
owned one pair of sneakers a year it was
the case with you know I had no clothes
I didn't go out yeah I didn't do [ __ ]
yeah like I didn't have a BMW yeah I
don't know man I kept it simple cuz I
loved the game one thing I tweeted today
I'm really trying to figure this out cuz
I don't want to be as lame or as vanilla
as like love the process unfortunately
that's the answer
yeah like if you just love what you
[ __ ] do for real for real yeah well
then you probably have a shot if you
love what you do and you're patient and
you actually mentally give up your 20s
and early 30s
Shiki get crazy yeah I mean look at us
yeah but not so so I love that point and
this is where one of the things me and
Chris was talking about um a couple
weeks ago and you have brought it up
about this idea between perseverance and
delusion yeah and one of the things you
talked about your biggest thing which I
don't think I spent enough time talking
about bringing them you need to you need
to rant on black grills is that that's
there
Facebook community tween I'm serious how
many people right now goodness we me hey
yeah so me take this go ahead I don't
want to take away I'll go ahead and do
it man go and do so what what's the name
in the podcast it's called the roommates
podcast oh yeah I think you're on the
other side yo it's a roommates podcast
at roommates my roommates HC oh yeah
going one more time because I'm guys I'm
about to cut you off and have to hear
the rest of it on their podcast hey it's
a roommates podcast go ahead and look us
up SoundCloud iTunes all that good stuff
and also look at us up on social media
at roommates HDX they're two htx
yeah all right keep going yeah so the
biggest thing that you talked about was
like your superpower is your patience
right your superpower is your ability to
be like you know what a little
perspective okay go ahead
patience is a byproduct of my
perspective real right like like my
perspective in the macro is there's
abundance in the world mm-hmm
my perspective is like most people are
good yeah my perspective is nobody's
victories are taking out of mine mm-hmm
my perspective is like fine good always
be patient if you're good enough you
will win because by virtue like by
structure mm-hmm if you were good enough
you would have figured it out yeah yeah
if you weren't good enough
it means you dwelled on being a minority
by being a woman by having a bad boss by
having an alcoholic dad by growing up in
Phoenix like I don't know sorry Phoenix
you know like yeah like by virtue being
good means net-net did you win
yeah yeah and so all these people that
are like but I was good but I got
[ __ ] taken advantage of no you didn't
and so my perspective one of the pillars
of my perspective is patience it just
makes sense my man little into a hundred
years old how old are you 27 you 24
right and now somebody's gonna leave a
comment be like look applause or cancer
I get it
but at a macro it's very likely that you
guys are gonna live for 70 more years
yeah and when you actually take that
into account I don't know like maybe you
should start doing different maybe all
of a sudden like eating [ __ ] for a year
as an intern for a [ __ ] G even though
you're not getting paid a lot is smart
not stupid my man I'm telling you right
now it's crazy I'm thinking about
working for Mark Cuban and Bezos and zux
and me Diddy for a year for free if I'm
doing that I'm literally not joking that
like something happens when there's a
transition like Disney comes and offers
me eight billion for this or or Marcus
becomes the CEO or Andre or like if
there's a transition moment I'm not
joking yeah I'm a literally at 48 at 54
have a transition year where I intern
for somebody with a Billy in my bank
yeah yeah no yeah it's funny it's easy
it's actually easier to do it free b-24
and having nothing than being 48 and
having a billy hmm the [ __ ] am I going
to intern for free and wasting my time
at 48 yeah after I did for 30 years
that's harder actually let's talk about
actions all right what the [ __ ] am i
doing on this podcast you are yeah when
people [ __ ] on me like like I know
people listen right now and I know you
have an audience of people that don't
know me right yeah and they're like
trying to calibrate what's going on
right now right yeah actions time is
what we're talking about let's be real
right number one cuz I'm is what we're
talking about right I should not by any
stretch of the imagination be doing this
podcast right what's not zero
like my comms team my PR team gets so
mad at me I'm passing on Wall Street
Journal CNBC seeing I'm passing on [ __ ]
all day long
yeah covers a magnet passing pass pass
pass busy busy in her life what am I
doing here
it's um living my truth which is like
what are we all doing I think it's good
ideas to [ __ ] live humble as [ __ ] in
your 20s stop worrying about what other
people think about you don't live for
somebody else which means your parents
and your boys and girls you're living
for your parents or your friends like
you need a BMW for one reason to
leverage it in society to show who you
are mmm you can't love driving it enough
to put yourself in more debt that's true
you can't don't [ __ ] with me I hate when
people [ __ ] me they love it [ __ ] you
you don't love it you love what it gets
you you want to hook up you think it's a
leverage point period hmm you want to
show people you made it you didn't waste
your time you made it since you see me
last in high school I made it yeah
you're worried about other people's
opinions yeah I say go inside your own
[ __ ] head and do right [ __ ] first for
yourself yeah I am sitting on this
podcast right now cuz I ate [ __ ] for 15
years out the gate which gives me the
luxury now to put other people on I love
it
I'm putting you on issue what's gonna
happen after this you're gonna promote
it I'm gonna give it a little share I
just did a little promotion now they
want to see it you can get a whole new
audience but way more importantly that
people aren't smart way more important
that you're about to get any guest you
want yeah number one asset is time I got
a lot of pressures guys I got a ton of
[ __ ] going on I cancel a trip to
Tennessee today in my own office is 9th
anniversary problem party there I got 40
disappointing employees and Chattanooga
Tennessee right now I cancelled
Wednesday to go out to Chicago for a big
piece of business cuz I got [ __ ] to do
right now internally and I'm [ __ ]
sitting here with you two jokers right
right because I'm giving loves yeah I
love it
that's my version of 42 and winning yeah
so if I'm doing that what's your news I
hate when the 24 year old I'm 22 easy
for you millionaire easy for you [ __ ]
you you don't know me yeah you don't
know me off that you know Commons right
now guys I mean it's it's the 90% silent
guy know all the love you see for me on
social and I get
plenty of love like at the opposite I
got people who think I'm [ __ ] walking
on water I get it yeah
you have thirst and I'm so passionate to
help these people that are sitting and
making excuses right now yeah because
it's just perspective yeah like it's
just it's just me it just switch it yeah
d-roc became dramatically
d-roc had patience and willing to eat
[ __ ] which is special yeah that's why it
but but what I gave d-roc perspective
wise was creative subjective get out
your own [ __ ] eliminate you don't have
ego as a guy you have ego in your work
and get rid of that ego egos [ __ ]
dangerous people confuse my confidence
and my optimism for ego yeah and I may
have you go to I don't you know these
are semantics now but I'm telling right
now the people that know me best think
I'm humble not that I have an ego no and
that is what this is all about I
absolutely love it and I couldn't even
agree more like I think that's the one
thing that we try to do that really
caused us to gravitate so much to use
that you're doing this out of love and
to add value to people's lives no you're
not users nice I want because by the way
I'm not [ __ ] the best guy on earth
it's because I want legacy yeah
people out here chasing money [ __ ] money
like money is important I get it you're
cool like like money's cool look I get
it yeah we don't money's best for
freedom yeah you could do what you want
when you want but you don't need a lot
of money for that
yeah understand we're yachts and the
boats and the [ __ ] Rolexes and like
and by the way if you love that ship
Mazel Tov do you I'm telling you right
now um I'm doing it cuz I'm not like
listen I want legacy you know how nice
it is that your daughter's gonna send me
a whatever to [ __ ] a text message isn't
that day yeah well no again kind of my
zio Achilles from Troy consume content
bro what I don't watch movies like that
all you know what's very man ready for
this okay I watched one or two movies a
year and they all happen to say actually
let me I don't wanna [ __ ] so you
ready for this
I watched either two or four movies a
year here's how it goes i watch -
usually cuz i'll watch two movies
between Christmas and New Year's know
cuz I'm off the grid with the fam check
it out good [ __ ] comes out
I'm gonna do something right I mean the
wife will go check out movie - boom
I may catch two others on some long-ass
trip on a flight when the wife is [ __ ]
up and I got him all my work done and I
got no choice but even the last time
that happened
I dropped the airplane project because I
was amazing because I just got motivated
and it was like I saw a movie I got
watch the movie I watch a Tupac movie
what was your fine yeah I liked it I
liked it cuz I loved the story it was
like a great yeah but like the sport he
loved I love Tupac yeah and then what
happened I had more time and I was like
instead of watching another movie I'm
like I'm gonna drive actually you know
the rock we need to like resurface the
airplane actually you know what can you
make a note in your ear that it's the
one-year anniversary of the airplanes
project we need to go hard and push it
again cuz that [ __ ] is evergreen
Universal that wasn't time [ __ ] that
wasn't like use Facebook like this use
Instagram like that that was like
[ __ ] thesis [ __ ] mmm yeah rockin we
tell you do some things but go look for
seven years solo making my ship is where
there was a dear honor with you so going
back to the point about perseverance
versus delusions yes let's talk about
that because you made a really great
point like this to people there's two
people and working right now one person
let's just use rap because rapid okay
easy one rappers both of them my yo I
love Gary Vee I'm out the grind six
years put my head down to look at no
numbers just work work work work work
work work one rapper is gonna win it's
gonna win one of them is gonna lose
because let me tell you what you're
looking for and I'm glad you bring the
stuff in you're helping me
yeah you need to see something yeah hmm
I think people are looking for
everything yeah and I think the person
that's delusional doesn't see anything
okay
like a year in she's got nothing another
year in she's got nothing and what I
mean nothing it's like you need to see
you need to see [ __ ] yeah you need to
see your spot if I go up yeah I need to
get more set like listen if you're a
rapper out there and you're two years in
and you drop 30 songs 50 songs 100 songs
and you're basically around the same
numbers you're in trouble
mmm yeah but if you've seen a little
something then you got something
I see a little something yeah
we seen a little something yeah like the
reason I win is I see a little something
by the way sometimes it goes the other
way d-roc has our YouTube numbers views
doing nice and steady and [ __ ]
we're flat as [ __ ] yeah why cuz the
audience on YouTube doesn't want to see
what I'm putting out on dailyvee here's
the good news I believe in what I'm
doing I think I'll be historically
correct I'm documenting I'm not
producing sitcoms and entertainment on
YouTube like so many of the people that
are winning I'm not hacking that tile as
much I'm not tagging the title as much
I'm not hacking the content within if I
[ __ ] did an interview of Richard
Branson and we're both jumping out of a
[ __ ] jet and were skydiving and
that's the interview it would give you
do it yeah I know how to do it yeah I
don't want to do that what I want to do
is put down a piece of work that nobody
else has put which is I'm putting out a
[ __ ] documentation a documentary that
has never been seen before and when
people take a step back and look at 20
years of daily be then I mean like
that's [ __ ] crazy
look you're literally literally gonna
see yourself in 17 years looking all
young and fresh and so like you know you
got to see something and so or you have
to know the mission you're on more you
just love it like listen if you don't
make in a hundred thousand a year or
forty thousand a year or a hundred fifty
thousand a year but you're doing your
rap on the side and you just love it
like you kind of deep down know that
you're never really really gonna be like
you know really Pollock little yachty
pops from the get yeah you know I hate
when people like what about yah team
like it happens it happens I'm just a
one two songs boom boom boom it happens
what about the people that were [ __ ]
hustling for seven years and then it
finally happened it happens gene of the
other world 2 Chainz that's exactly
right
right and so like sometimes you got to
change your name from titty boy yeah you
know like subtle Wow and so you know it
is what it is but I would say like real
simple I mean even Nipsey Hussle man
somebody who's been a fan of his for a
decade this last album was kind of like
where you went to that next place for
you you know um you know and so anyway
unless where I'm going the difference is
you got to see something yeah you got to
see a little bit of growth you got to
get that encouragement email you know
sometimes it's volumes sometimes it's
impact let me explain
Tirra whack let's talk about tira whack
somebody I really really believe in okay
she's gonna be big she just put out a
project and it got real love you're like
what does she look like her numbers
haven't super exploded sweeties exploded
much more right like she her numbers and
last little bit tears numbers didn't
blow up as much as I thought they would
on insta from this last little batch but
the comment from Meek Mill of like
you're gonna be a legend the tweet from
Missy Elliott like you're next
that's seeing something yeah you know
understands real so it might be just a
DM from Oprah like keep going girl
you've got this or it might be boom you
put on a song got a million listens
right Saba up in Chicago like blah blah
you know he's grinded he's grinded you
know I see little thing it's little it's
little like I wasn't it when he was on
the cosign by chance on that album that
went completely ballistic it wasn't
angels yeah it was but it wasn't
yeah right um I don't know man like it's
so obvious to me but here's what I would
say
you're delusional if you've been doing
something for 24 36 months and you're
kind in the same place mmm
you're you're being patient if it's like
a slow like you can't be climbing a
mountain and three years later you're
still at the base mmm but it's okay if
you're only 1/10 of the way there that
means you made some [ __ ]
progress that's real that's real that's
the good yeah you know is really good at
this comedians mmm oh my god meaning is
[ __ ] for a long time like Kevin Hart was
grinding for a long time Hasan Minhaj is
about to have his moment he was been
grinding for a long time all these
comedians been grinding for a long time
and now Netflix came they didn't know
Netflix was coming along yeah and
rebooting the late-night special now
they're all being put on right yes the
mediums are more in culture now because
of Netflix that's right yeah I think we
asked ourselves that all the time and we
always won't we always go back like to
the rappers in the comedian's of the
world we always go back to why we do
this we know we have this podcast
because we want to impact people and
it's our vehicle to do that
so we know our why and we also look at
the results we know that you know it's
selfish by with myself because
everybody's algebra stick as [ __ ] even
notice how you guys brought up like Gary
we know you do out of love and
immediately I jump in and say cool but
also I want statutes yeah yeah I got one
number 14 to be a national [ __ ]
holiday yeah really get crazy
a couple more selfish nuts off yes this
why is the next decade or two
don't give me do not let me buy the Jets
at 57 for 61 you are because if you give
me 30 years yeah
I'll be on some Dali Lama like you like
real heavy [ __ ] with like like I'm like
all right who's got we got presidents we
got Martin Luther King like [ __ ]
Columbus I'm like how the [ __ ] over the
next 30 years do I make November 14th my
[ __ ] birthday a national holiday and
it's gonna be sucky because it's close
to Thanksgiving I do it cuz I want I
want the admiration yeah because I'm
trying to still scratch the itch my mom
admired loved hived me so heavy that the
only people don't get it the only way to
really go there to that like real place
is to give not take real like nobody
gives like do you know how many
billionaires there are that you've never
heard of that are on a yacht right now
popping champagne and you think it's
great but nobody gives a [ __ ] about them
and there are three kids from four
marriages are gonna [ __ ] it which of the
math doesn't even work under you know
actually does one of them didn't have
kids you know like yeah you know they're
all gonna fight for the fortune cuz yeah
he or she they didn't do the right thing
and putting it like people don't get
legacy that's really so what's you know
cool that's very nice that you're nice
boys
I think the reason I'm putting pressure
on education is really have more truth
out there that's wrong people right now
everyone's on like I want to heal the
world you'll be thrilled if that happens
as well yeah I think it's super
important
all the best things I do charity help in
all this stuff like quiet stuff only
Tyler D Rock some of these people know
the best parts of me as a person or
unknown mmm when you bring up my name a
lot of people ago that said dude that's
crazy that wants to buy the Jets that
sounds like a dick yeah yeah yeah so
like I'm not scared to own myself as
[ __ ] as a matter of fact I put more
light on my selfish [ __ ] than on my
selfless [ __ ]
I let mice my mouth is selfish my
actions are selfless hmm because the
actions are the truth yeah all these
people that are about the culture and
the community and young entrepreneurs
they are yeah they may write a $5,000
check to a contest to look good yeah but
are they sitting with you for 45 minutes
giving up the actual asset nope no so
Chris what is your selfish wife good
question and then Chris the key here man
is to not be full of [ __ ] cuz you have
to understand it it's liberating like
and it's really simple is it Fame yeah
is it money
yeah is it experiences that those two
things bring like I think it's amazing
to want to be like LeBron and jump off a
cliff on 4th of July weekend I think
you're amazing to be like Khalid getting
yelled at for even though he told the
conference that he wasn't gonna be there
being in pool with his kid live in that
life yeah like I think it's amazing if
you want to have like your 7 you know
supermodels laying on the deck of your
yeah that's good pic of you I don't want
that I'd rather be garage sale in on
Saturday girl because that's what I love
I love chachi cuz look at my [ __ ]
office like cool everybody's gone
there's like what's yours for real for
real for real [ __ ] for rose I
haven't caught him oh my father Chris
is the money okay I've always always
desired in like the ID what do you want
to buy with it see a lot of people ask
me that
I think he's experienced it's really
just experiences like what like what
yeah not only loves you want to go look
at the pyramids and or dream is you want
to take your actress girlfriend on the
ribs you know I don't do some now tell
you why that's important yeah
let's say it's nasty things actress
right man then you could start talking
about like you probably need the money
but maybe you don't yeah and maybe what
you definitely need to do is move to LA
mm-hmm I want to buy the New York Jets
yeah everything I do professionally
mm-hm it's about buying the New York
Jets
that was you but it's not right selling
a big piece of my company to Steve Ross
the owner to Miami Dolphins is not easy
when you know you're giving it away yeah
Wow oh girl right mmm uh passing on a
$200,000 speaking gig to go speak for
free to the owners and Aspen Colorado
cuz you want a build relationship not
easy guys you got it that's true when
you know what the [ __ ] you're up to it
impacts your [ __ ] decisions mm-hmm
the problem is most people don't
synthesize what the [ __ ] they're up to
mm-hmm it's vanilla as [ __ ] like I want
money cool next why why why you know
this is this is pretty easy but for me I
want a Sistine Chapel like kind of like
in your sense like I want to be the
greatest ever to do something I want to
have something that I've created what
that thing is well there's two things
potentially right now so it's it's a
book and it's also a movie so those are
the two things and then the third thing
can potentially be just like hands on
impact in people's lives like I think a
super adult like Gandhi Oprah like a one
name person you know Malcolm X Martin
Luther came to that's two names but like
I kind of want my legacy in regards to
like I've absolutely
change people's lives like like in your
sense like so what's important about
that is you got to think about so
self-awareness matters right so to me I
didn't realize that 25 how much I wanted
to teach and give back yeah I just
didn't at first it was just like help my
family business hmm
so you know when it gets that heady that
early yeah and I think that's you're a
man of the time right like this is not
the [ __ ] that 25 27 29 year olds were
spitting two decades ago right you know
you need to be thoughtful about that if
that's the truth yeah you've got some
big advantages number one money's not
part of that equation it's not not for
me not at all it's not a fact I would
never buy a home if that's your goal I
would never buy a home like no like I'm
like no [ __ ] you like I I've been
this way for a long time oh they know
like I don't care about money like
coming here like we're gonna interview
interview bunch people like us losing
the monster
what's your Instagram my Instagram
Hafeez HTML on me h AF o h AF two E's
yep and a Z yep
h TX Henry Theodore exam I apologize
because I got confused by something h AE
h AF two E's yep and a Z yep and an HT x
Henry Theodore Xavier my dad taught me
that you know he's from Nigeria is a
Nigerian accent so whenever he does
whatever he says a letter he ever I
followed you okay thank you get a follow
Chris - I will maybe I won't just to
make it funny that will be I don't I'll
sleep fine maybe tonight I'll think
about it
jeez I'm real proud of you man
appreciate you
the first thing I really wanted to see I
love I love [ __ ] people that [ __ ]
live their truth yeah you are in your
comments my guy oh yeah of course but to
me that's the first one like yeah this
one you didn't get to the eastern one
but like it thank you
I actually told them get the head no we
meet Gary and honestly like you're gonna
ask all of our listeners like we
literally are number one job is every
comment every email every day you know
what now I'm gonna get mad at you
because your last three posts you were
in it but the [ __ ] four post before
that not a single person let me let me
tell you something that matters
okay check this out so at least were you
[ __ ] killed right yeah but this only
eight comments nobody's got a reply
right oh dang no no there and that post
before that nobody got a reply right now
let me show you another thing nobody got
a reply on that one here we go read back
now the fourth one back twelve comments
no reply and there's a book behind you
right no reply on the post before that
that yellow book that orange book that's
the most important book I ever wrote
it's called the Thank You economy yeah
you know how people like will give me
something how you got there like [ __ ]
don't give me motivation give me details
here's my details yeah from 2007 to 2012
I replied to every email and every tweet
that I got period all of them I went to
sleep at 3 o'clock in the morning every
night hmm five years all of them yeah if
you want to change the world yeah you
need to change person by person by
person to show them you give a [ __ ]
Ezrin so what you need to do right now
is on the flight home or wrong I'll do
it every one of them I'm gonna do it I
believe you accountable today now you do
by the end of the day because like
that's the answer man I love it cuz it
will work I love it no I know by one by
one it's real people the last three
posts on Instagram that you reply to ya
feel differently about you than the 5
posts before that that's where you
applied to no one that's real em you
ain't gonna live you're not telling us
how we love Gary Vee you know what it is
you know how I got here yeah I just know
how I got here yeah like you know the
one thing that makes my life so fun is I
just talk about the [ __ ] that's the
truth to me and to other people that
I've seen been successful yeah and then
a lot of things I see other people being
successful at and I don't talk about it
yeah people like Gary Vee talk about
this talk about that I'm like not real
to me
yeah even even social issues sometimes
people like Gary Vee you need to [ __ ]
tweet about this I'm like like everybody
else who looks like a keyboard warrior
yeah you don't know me you know what I'm
doing behind the scenes you know I'm
meeting with you know I'm writing checks
- you don't know what I'm doing yeah so
it's an inside game yes real keyboard
warrior desperella
yeah everybody's great is it really
super down with it yeah one [ __ ]
Twitter the [ __ ] are you actually doing
yeah not absolutely love it I love it
ain't anything else crisp everyone be
respectful of a man's time I mean I know
I've been I've been cussed out today
tell me what's been going on how's this
been going hope ease oh you want me to
do it yeah oh yeah no it's been good
it's been it's been a lot of ups there's
been a lot of downs I think the biggest
thing that's really been dope is we've
had a lot of opportunities with exposure
wise so like for example like we got an
episode on own Network show the book of
John Gray so got that exposure we got we
were on Fox News 26 we made a short film
to get our mental health and so so we
did a podcast then we did a film that we
were on Fox News for that one feature
Houston Chronicle Houstonian magazine
Houston style and I was trying to
surprise you with this one but we're
gonna be featured and that Lanting that
they're doing this piece on like
roommates and like roommates it and
roommate and relationship so they they
reached out to us we had a long and how
long has this been going on 78 weeks
early yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
the base thing but like we could you
call him er will he hurt me because it's
the truth but like we could this is good
because you know I watched I love you I
was watching a long time yeah like you
didn't want that you don't want that on
wax yeah yeah yeah yeah know what I mean
yeah but I saw you I was happy yeah I
did it because I want you to win yeah
yes this is the point I made earlier
yeah
I'm not [ __ ] making Instagram
comments to be like I'm cool and you
suck yeah I'm trying to be like yo yeah
stop [ __ ] talking and do you this is
your only [ __ ] life [ __ ]
yeah you know this is it this is it yeah
I don't want people like you know people
being mad at me on worldstar
like being like [ __ ] this guy yeah that
doesn't hurt me go and see in somebody
92 who Brett's their whole [ __ ] life
that hurts me 18-year old Charlie and
[ __ ] Alabama was like [ __ ] this guy
yeah it's early for him yes 92 year old
Gertrude Beatrice and it's rude I don't
know why it affected me from the get I
don't know why I hung out with old
people when I was young yeah I should go
to the playground and just jump on like
the bench with the [ __ ] grandparents
you know ask them about the Kennedy
assassination and asked them about NASA
and ask them about World War two I don't
know why you know my report card is a
piece of [ __ ] hanging
new book history for some reason is good
grades I don't know why I respect the
past so much I think over time I
realized cuz it tells me the future yeah
I'm not guessing out here it's rural I'm
not [ __ ] guessing out here yeah I'm
not doing that they're cool no I'm doing
that because I don't do that now yeah I
don't plan everybody yeah
but [ __ ] five years I did you know why
cuz I was at zero yeah yeah I was at
zero yeah
zero that's bro that's real knows
absolutely Lebanon so and by the way for
everybody [ __ ] yeah go ahead it's
like cuz I need people understand I was
at zero after working my [ __ ] dick
off for 15 years building a huge
business for my dad yeah like do not get
me confused and do not use me as an
excuse that's I did it better than
everybody yeah I [ __ ] came out the
gate worked gave up all my 20s no
[ __ ] fun no [ __ ] fun and gave back
to my parents for bringing me to America
and then at 34 I started hmm sound like
whoo man do you understand that no we
understand that's powerful it's like
[ __ ] cuz people out here crying at 27
and their parents are paying for their
uber mm-hmm you know what I mean yes
like let's get [ __ ] serious out here
yeah you better find somebody else to
use as an excuse because I see it I read
it who am i mad at I'm mad at the person
who's got a friend who's like I love
guaranteed like yeah [ __ ] that guy his
dad gave him three million dollars mine
didn't give me three million dollars
yeah
the business was doing three million on
10% profit 300,000 for all those I can't
do math that was before expenses I
walked in that [ __ ] place
you know honestly I'm under estimating
what I did mmm I'm the reason I've got
fire right now I was at a week to think
yeah I spent some time with my dad I
[ __ ] came in did [ __ ] yeah and gave
up all the [ __ ] that everybody's worried
about on Instagram I didn't flow in any
[ __ ] swans hmm I didn't go to the
[ __ ] Polo Hamptons this yeah I had no
[ __ ] weekend's you know what it looks
like to live your entire twenties
working Saturday in a [ __ ] liquor
store from 8:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every
[ __ ] Saturday mm-hmm so I don't want
to hear [ __ ]
yeah period that's what's up see ya and
that's why he's a legend so guys make
sure you go ahead and throw Gary some
love as we've always said guys continue
to support who he brought on the show
Gary where can they find you on social
media Gary Vee guys I mean go ahead and
find him guy sent him a DM a tweets and
I'm a mess let him know how much we
appreciate how much you value him Gary
we appreciate you man
you